oh
[Musique]
ils arrivent du monde entier pour
assister à l'une des étapes mythiques du
tour de france le mont ventoux
passionné de vélo il se retrouve pendant
quelques jours pour vivre au rythme de
cet immense rassemblement populaire à
une semaine du passage du tour
les camping cars a fuit déjà par
milliers
[Musique]
les places sont chères
il faut dénicher l'emplacement idéal
installés confortablement son petit chez
soi sans oublier d'afficher fièrement
ses couleurs
pour tous ces amoureux de la grande
boucle venir au ventoux est l'occasion
de découvrir une région et de partager
un grand moment de convivialité
christian et micheline suivent le tour
de france depuis 25 ans ils vivent à la
rochelle et ont parcouru plus de mille
kilomètres pour voir les coureurs c'est
grâce au tour de france si je découvre
le vaucluse en fait depuis le temps que
je voulais venir ou en tout ça déplace
des montres des montagnes de camping
vous savez combien il ya campi car ils
ont compté 950 là et la 950 et ils en
ont compté 450 dans les descentes dans
les descentes jusqu'au mont ventoux on a
devrait 1300 camping car la risée de
lenovo et 1300 camping ker alors à 1330
picard à deux personnes un minimum
savait déjà 2600 personnes auxquelles a
réveillé voire de baudouin à environ dix
mille personnes
bédouin c'est un peu la capitale du move
en touche à quelques jours du passage du
tour
la petite commune de 2600 habitants est
en ébullition on attend le passage
c'est mieux que les camping caristes
vous avez le prix hors domicile pour
pour le maire luc reynard l'enjeu est de
taille
la population de bédouin a multiplié par
100 et côté organisation rien ne doit
être laissé au hasard pour aujourd'hui
ça risque ça risque d'être un peu juste
aujourd'hui ça risque d'être un peu
juste la cour de mails à bordeaux même
peut-être mais il faudrait que je les
vois en dépit de quelques inquiétudes
on préfère voir le bon côté de cette
arrivée massive de touristes
on empile
ça y est ça s'empressa variera on a de
quoi s'occuper
ça passait vite c'est que du bonheur sur
le territoire de la commune on va faire
200 250 mille personnes au minimum
levant tôt et pratiquement saturés
puisque les camping-cars affluent depuis
de nombreux jours certains se sont
installés à la fraîcheur et c'est assez
plaisant que d'aller les voir chacun
attend patiemment mais ils regardent le
spectacle parce que c'est déjà un
spectacle en soi que de voir passer
notre camping-car qu de voir des
cyclistes viennent de de toutes
nationalités avec tous les équipements
c'est un spectacle très chamarrés et
surtout c'est la bonne ambiance c'est
l'ambiance du tour
[Musique]
les camping cars ne sont pas les seuls à
s'être donné rendez vous les cyclistes
amateurs venus du monde entier
gravissent la montagne sur les traces de
leur champion et c'est un sacré défi
survivre
je suis ravi je suis très contente en
fait du bien de recevoir et ça fait une
semaine qu'on fait un raid et on a déjà
fait 500 km en vélo et là c'est notre
derniers jours de raids
voilà donc je pensais pas être capable
de le monter ce que je n'avais plus rien
dans les jambes ce matin et puis je suis
contente parce que j'ai fait en 2 heures
10 donc je suis très très contente c'est
toujours magnifique d'être ici avec le
peuple avec les cyclistes ne sais c'est
incroyable c'est c'est comme commettre
fou hein c'est comme ça
c'est même très joli la magie du tour
elle a déjà commencé ici de deux jours
avant est ok l'habitude de le monter
avec bon il ya beaucoup de cyclistes
mais il y a personne au bord et là c'est
sympa comme on nous encourage on a
l'impression d'être des coureurs sur le
tour
si certains courent après la performance
pour d'autres l'essentiel est ailleurs
au colbert soir les toiles de tente le
feu d'artifice des pétards le ricard sa
ya les uns c'est au tour de france une
fête populaire
alors tout on y va un essai gratuit
encore c'est gratuit et à manger à
manger pour vivre jour j'ai qu'un site
de rozé j'ai trois listes de ricker 3,8
de pino je peux dire huit jours moi j'ai
de tout et je n'ai pas
[Musique]
l'un des bateaux
normand départ du circuit
koman son ordonnance et les camping cars
le moment tout il faut le savoir est
interdit au camping aucun manning de
morlaàs pour le tour de france est une
c'est une dérogation c'est une exception
et donc il faut bien que chacun se
persuade que c'est une faveur et que
tout le monde joue le jeu
pour les organisateurs confort du public
et préservation du massif sont
indissociables
bruno paul travaille pour le département
de vaucluse sa mission s'assurer que
tous les déchets se retrouve bien dans
les poubelles
on va commencer à
en effet un petit peu les gamines
cariste pour leur dire de
ramasser les poubelles on va distribuer
quelques sacs pas beaucoup mais quelques
sacs un groupe qui viennent d'arriver là
major
zack hall à la femme le passé refait un
passage par jour alertés dimanche
voilà est bon pour deux points merci mr
merci au revoir mais ça ne va pas je
reviens
pour le court ça oui d'accord les
données je passerai djoum effacés
d'accord d'accord c'est bien très bonne
journée voire certaines des précautions
pour sauvegarder le site ne font pas
l'unanimité en droit de faire des
barbecues ont rien ils sont passé un cap
a fait cuire les saucisses j'ai fait un
bon contre-la-montre à pink est recruté
le verre partout oh là là c'est plus à
présent comme l'humeur je crois dans mon
compliqué je veux dire que votre empire
maquillage chez les suspects les blagues
et voilà un plus ça fait quand même nom
mais tais-toi l'aide ses propres il ya
une femme de ménage qui vient tous les
jours
et puis bon on a de quoi vider nos
cassettes c'est pendant le sait bien que
son régional y en a 10 ans oui ils ont
bien joué et s'est lancée dimanche selon
fait de la non non le conseil l'a puis
bon ils font des ronds naïve viennent
voir et regarde encore ignorées du feu
où les gens feront fondée par le cul ou
à charbon de bois
ils nous ont interdit tandis qu'au gaz
au caucase
donc non c'est bien et la police aussi
fait des romains
[Musique]
les spectateurs bien installé profitent
de leur nouvel espace de vie le bord de
la route se transforme peu à peu en camp
de vacances
[Musique]
le ventoux c'est l'occasion de retrouver
ses amis et de faire de nouvelles
rencontres
je viens j'aime le vent doux avant tout
c'est ma tasse de thé nous entoure
et j'aime bien venir passer quelques
jours avec
il engage comme enki on trouve
difficilement ailleurs épouse rose et
jaune ne leur mets pas trop d'autres je
vais aller noyer leurs cette année je
comprends pas tous les engins maillot
jaune avec la carte de france il ya
parcours 2011 2012 et en 2013 ils font
pas de carte ils vont ils ont marqué
juste il ya la carte de france son
jugement le 100e il fallait se base sur
le camping harris et ça vous arrivez
dans un endroit vous connaissez pas une
heure après vous êtes à la paire an ces
cinq entités moi quand j'ai vu une belle
tête comme ça on a parlé non mais c'est
sympa quand pécari c'est convivial on se
connaît pas puis après on se connaît on
se pense à nos adresses tout ça on se
téléphone ont fait des voyages
c'est ça moi j'ai déjà fait ça mais on
verra beaucoup que je connus qui étaient
là et là j'ai retrouvé deux campings
caristes qui était avec moi au au col de
pailhères
les discussions vont bon train ce qu'on
appelle le trou charente et quand elle
ne meurt pas au milieu du repas qui
révèle un bon petit pineau [__] moi je
sais comment cet essai de assez
touchante chacun y va de son pronostic à
penser que 14 juillet un jour de fête
nationale
on espère bien une histoire française
chavanel peut peut-être nous faire un
cours est celui d'un banal jeu pas moins
une des soins jusqu'à présent chavanel
oh la la
d'abord je suis pas que leur il passe
ici quatre ans et demi au sirop ci roule
à 40 de ses 4h30 s'ils sont à 39 de
moyenne il pense à 16h50 la ici la feps
commencerez au col de la tempête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'arrivée de tous ces touristes est une
occasion rêvée pour les producteurs
locaux leur meilleur marché de l'année
il on profite pour vendre leurs produits
mais aussi pour vanter leurs enjeux
on y voit bruno habitent sur le versant
nord à quelques kilomètres du sommet
ce matin il a délaissé ses sacs poubelle
pour s'atteler à l'entretien des routes
indispensable à la sécurité des nombreux
cycles
là il a remonté à peu près 1000 par jour
tout le
sur le sommet reprises
la descente de
[Musique]
importante de la moins grave est que les
faits reprochés
alors voici que de suite à se sont
ajoutés la paille et 53 la plesse vous
êtes à 5 cm
la main d'un jour là il faut toujours
être vigilant donc je passe le deux fois
par jour
pour
pour faire le balayage
[Musique]
c'est la tradition les supporters
peignent des messages d'encouragement
pour leur champion il ya deux ans
j'étais déjà là
super super partout je viens de hollande
je suis aussi la course du dauphiné
libéré et je peux à chaque étape
qu'est ce que vous pensez de l'étape du
ventoux ventoux
[Musique]
cette terrible réputation le mont
ventoux la doit en partie à la mort du
coureur anglais tom simpson en 1967 à
quelques kilomètres du sommet simpson
est victime d'une terrible défaillance
à l'époque les coureurs n'ont droit qu'à
2 litres d'eau pendant l'étape
la fatigue la chaleur et surtout le
dopage conduite au drame
cette mort filmée en direct marque à
jamais l'histoire du tour de france tom
simpson est devenu une légende du sport
britannique pour rendre hommage à son
champion john voight n'auraient pour
rien au monde manqué l'étape du ventoux
tomtom simpson était d'ailleurs le
champion du monde quand j'étais gamin
partie d'un club cycliste
il était notre héros voulait gravir le
ventoux depuis que j'ai 11 ans tombe
simpson est mort je suis parti de
bédouin j'ai gravi la côte jusqu'à stèle
je me suis arrêté pour le saluer j'ai
continué jusqu'au sommet sur la stèle
érigée en sa mémoire
on peut lire aucune montagne net à ses
hôtes en guise d'offrande chacun y
dépose ce qu'il a sous la main
le tribut à payer ou vendre la mort je
ne trouve pas normal c'est qu'il est je
sers la csu une bouteille là les bidons
encore d'accord une chambre à air
mont ventoux pour moi c'est le monstre
au delà de la provence pour à ses yeux
le patriarche le maître je suis là je
domine tous les venait me chercher
là on marche ou pas c'est cool les
coureurs on est tu as la limite quand
ils vont passer on peut presque les
toucher qu'il faut pas faire bien
évidemment on descend on y voit on nous
après la télé c'est l'autre et c'est
l'ambiance surtout l'ambiance y avoir
une ambiance de fête c'est formidable
c'est qu'à la télé on peut voir l'étape
de départ à l'arrivée tandis qu'at on
voit que le la montée du col du vent
tourne on apprend du départ mais le
principal c'est dans l'action même pour
lier que cinq minutes on est dans
l'action
les préparatifs se poursuivent
à la veille du grand jour le maire de
bedoin tient à faire une halte dans le
célèbre virage de synthèse brega
c'est là où les choses sérieuses
commencent c'est un des rares aux
endroits où on a une montée qui est
régulière et continue
c'est à dire on sait que quand on
commence cette ascension et même depuis
le village de bédouins et bien on m'a
pédaler pendant 21 km 300 quoi qu'il
arrive on ne peut pas se permettre le
moindre relâchement
il est vrai aussi que le tour de france
il ya tellement de légende parfois
malheureuses mais aussi des exploits il
ya tellement d'exploit on a tellement vu
à la télévision en internat but après
ceux des photos du ventoux où c'est
vraiment ce sont vraiment les forçats de
la route on les voit on les voit
transpirer on les voit pratiquement
défailli on les voit manqué d'oxygène
que l'on se dise et 1 c'est un terrible
supplice eu mille fois les sur place au
rendement comme de de se construire
service terminé pour bruno il troque la
balayeuse pour sa bicyclette et
s'attaque toujours avec le même entrain
à son ascension fétiche gens vendent en
moyenne 1,5 à 2 fois par heure à peu
près moi c'est une passion
je viens je fais par passion donc c'est
mort c'est mon jardin ici ouais ouais
ouais bah oui voilà alors voilà je me
c'est un plaisir de monter
demain le tour de france et donc c'est
quand même assez impressionnant à voir
si comme bigard mais à chaque tour de
france c'est comme ça il ya peu près ça
remplit le ça remplit quand même pas mal
le bord des routes là
et
4000 voir les camions la ligne d'arrivée
donc ça sera vrai j stable ces derniers
jours les gens peuvent accéder au sommet
dont le voit il ya des vélos partout ça
se passe bien car il n'y a pas de trop
de bagarres de hirsingue et ne pas trop
les gens c'est bon enfant voit ses jets
qu'ils arrivent là il n'y avait pas trop
le malaise je trouve le nombre de vélos
qui mode de para madrague pompiers ont
fait une dizaine de blessés sur le
sourire
en comparaison des 90 milles qui monte
et
[Musique]
je dois du lambon louis après très peu
gourmand les mouches ont changé d'âne et
poney cas pour aller en avion je vois
des trois étapes avec mon cousin maxi
corsa et l'avons plus avion survenu ici
regardez à charmer du tout va bien selon
m
les hommes font du vélo ils ont fait des
randonnées ont été visitées hier tous
les petits chalets tout ça avec la belle
étoile à l'apéro dans de nombreux
domaines l'apéro
dans les buvettes qui ont fleuri le long
de la route on se presse pour suivre la
retransmission du tour de france on
continue en de rêver à une victoire
française
enfin se fait rattraper à trois semaines
mais j'ai juste passé sous la halle les
gradins on a eu chaud autant je me suis
levé je connais les comptes et les pour
le pousser il n'a pas été plus vite
oh lala lala wane indicateurs voilà
alors on attend on aurait cru à une
victoire aujourd'hui même alors été
aujourd'hui alors français on s'en fout
de lui c'était paul 14 ans ont été une
victoire française le 13 mai manque de
pot demain mais je vois bien rolland
14 juillet 5 heures du matin sur le
sommet l'organisation du tour de france
prend possession de la montagne
130 camions et des centaines de
techniciens se met en place autour de la
ligne d'arrivée une ruche où chacun
connaît précisément son rôle
chaque véhicule est positionné au cm en
quelques heures tout doit être prêt une
chorégraphie parfaitement huilée qui se
répète chaque jour
[Musique]
certains spectateurs ont dormi sur place
alors que d'autres ont marché une partie
de la nuit pour ne rien rater du
spectacle est arrivé de pinchat en
belgique par luan maubeuge jusque
saumane en provence et ayez à midi on
est venu planter notre dame que au
parking à deux heures de marche ici et à
3 me ce matin s'est levé pour venir
ici à 6 heures apprend de petits d'âge
au resto bistro resto le sol création
mont ventoux le tour de france réunit
chaque jour trois milliards et demi de
téléspectateurs dans le monde pour
couvrir les exploits des coureurs
cyclistes
pas moins de 2000 journalistes sont
envoyés sur place
à 250 km de là à givors près de lyon au
départ de l'étape
l'énorme dispositif de la caravane
publicitaire se met en place
pas du tout
un sacré casse tête pour feront vieil
homme le responsable de ce convoi
exceptionnel
merci nous ne pouvons pas arrêter
l'auteur
[Musique]
dans 30 minutes un peu moins on va déjà
voir les premières caravanes qui vont
arriver pour approvisionnement en
goodies montage des décors donc ça fait
181 véhicules environ plus les
techniciens sont les équipes
d'encadrement de la caravane donc on a
environ 300 véhicules et 600 personnes
voilà une petite famille qui vit de
manière un peu autonome et indépendante
au coeur du tour de france non c'est mon
kart ou huit salles du gardon
[Musique]
timing serré il n'y a pas une minute à
perdre
cet immense cortège doit se mettre en
route deux heures avant le départ des
coureurs mais sa [__] un peu ton lui
montre lui moi je suis sûr qu'ils aient
si tu fais descendre en bas il fait
trois meneurs il sort on est trois
heures avant le départ de la caravane
cinq ans avant départ de la course et
c'est un moment un peu un peu cheap à ce
que tout le monde arrive sur un créneau
de 10 à 15 minutes et on prend le temps
aussi connaissance des lieux là on est
un peu compliqué on est sur un échangeur
d'autoroute sont que voilà il ya des
choses qui se bousculent mais ça se met
en place chacun sait ce qu'il doit faire
les chauffeurs connaissent bien les gars
donc chacun se fait confiance et bon
voilà c'est cette petite musique qu'on
répète tous les matins et reçoit un
petit moment le speed mais ça ça rentre
dans l'ordre et puis on va réussir à
caser tout le mond tranquillement pas
s'énerver
sur l'aéroport d'avignon michel
coupelles et son pilote s'apprête à
décoller
il dirige l'avion au les centres
névralgiques des communications du tour
de france l'avion un joli pea 31
bimoteur truffé d'antenne on en voit un
peu en dessous non un peu partout et
puis ben voilà c'est notre maison
journalières pendant trois semaines
grâce à radio tour
les directeurs de course transmettent
leurs instructions et donne les écarts
de temps à l'ensemble des participants
tous les véhicules de la qui sont sur la
course ont un récepteur radio tour donc
il ya un speaker qui le renvoie tous à
l'information
il ne rentre personnes sur la course qui
n'a pas avec lui dans son véhicule où
sur sa moto par ce soit un récepteur
radio passée en émission nos amis de
radio bleu pareil le squash le volume on
va pouvoir y aller c'est parti longue
journée
en effet tous les deux vont passer plus
de 6 heures à tourner en rond au-dessus
des coureurs
[Musique]
retour au ventoux dans leur camping car
micheline et christian prépare le
programme de l'après midi pour les
coureurs on va voir la caravane et coire
et puis après on en reviendra voir
l'arrivée à la télévision dans notre
camping car mais même des camping
caristes qui m'ont dit hier monsieur d'à
côté il va pas regarder la constance et
la regarder la télé monsieur par aig et
après on va attendre les premiers
coureurs quoi savoir ce qu'ils vont
s'échapper
espérons que c'est un français que le
petit voeckler va nous faire quelque
chose de venir ou chavanel quand même à
givors la caravane publicitaire est
enfin sur le départ comme les sportifs
les caravaniers s'échauffent
c'est quoi votre rôle vous le film
c'est un teaser extra pour
retient l'attention de la consommatrice
féminine
voilà on fait que les feuillages
ça
[Musique]
c'est quoi alors c'est le pré départ on
annonce cinq minutes avant aux hôtesses
qu'on va partir dans cinq minutes
voilà
barret
9h30 sur le mont ventoux on attend 400
mille personnes la route est prise
d'assaut par le public
les fous du vélo se sont donné rendez
vous pour une 1000 team ascension avant
le passage du tour la route est
surchargé
[Musique]
pas facile à gérer pour les
organisateurs
or on vient de recevoir un appel radio
comme quoi on doit arrêter tous les tous
les supplices ya trop de cyclisme à
roscoff récent des vélos ou quoi parce
que c'est fini la préfecture a dit
terminée la préfecture m'a compris ta
quête
la préfecture avait pressé tout on ne
serait pas venu jusqu'ici juste injuste
madame est dur il peut dire avant
malgré ces efforts le service de
sécurité est débordée et ne parvient pas
à stopper le flot de vélo qui se dirige
vers le sommet
un autre spectacle se joue sur la ligne
d'arrivée
à présent c'est à la télévision de faire
son show gérard holtz et son équipe
préparent leur émission quotidienne
[Musique]
après deux mois d'août
fabrice projet raoui 5 sur 5 rouges suis
content de t'avoir bon alors on fait un
petit point rapide avant de le mettre en
place mon idée ce serait d'apparaître
sous la sous la ligne je marche
ok on aura patienté dans la place when
wet équipage de la police michel ducros
métier
la répétition de son enregistrement ses
patientes et un public arabe
[Musique]
voilà la fameuse ligne d'arrivée de la
15e étape là où par exemple en 2010 dans
sa langue avait laissé gagner par la
police locale
[Musique]
10h à givors le moment tant attendu
arrive enfin
christian prudhomme le directeur de
course donne le départ de l'étape
[Applaudissements]
dans 230 km les coureurs atteindront le
pied du mont ventoux pour s'attaquer à
l'ascension du mythique géant de
provence
le speaker de radio tour donne ses
premières recommandations aux véhicules
en tête de plus râlant 10h ralentisseurs
très bon
talonné par le peloton la caravane nom
de la foule de goodies des petits
cadeaux plus de huit heures pendant
l'étape
cette hôtesse distribuera plus de quinze
mille paquets de bonbons
[Musique]
car seulement
ban
ces joutes ont devancé pour vous
[Musique]
vous faites de temps
on
du spectacle c'est que du jour
c'est du spectacle ambulant est à 30 à
l'heure
sa femme tipper essaie de faire sortir
que les fans
n'oublie pas de suite pensé à nous lors
la branche agressive
mon rôle c'est de donner ses mulets ou
10 euros
aujourd'hui sur le
pour la route
on s'y fait essentielle ment les femmes
l'aménageur avec avec des bons de
réduction à l'intérieur pour florange y
sommes le tour de france n'est pas
seulement un événement sportif
une personne sur deux présente sur le
tour de france dynamiquement pour la
carte du mystère qui sait
c'est parti du conseil de l'ordre ancien
la caravane et les quoi c'est un plus un
égale au tour de france c'est vrai que
l'on sait que les gens attendent en
moyenne six heures 40 sur bordeaux il ne
pourrait pas aussi longtemps ce n'est
pas quelque chose qui permettait
justement de faire passer ce saut temps
un petit peu à voir avec des cours qui
étaient assez éphémère finalement et
rapide
bonjour début de la caravane
publicitaire pour être sécurité merci de
rester sur le bas côté de la chaussée et
de ne pas traverser le lieutenant
frédéric ascarat ouvre la route
7 heures le feu reste ici sinon le
torchis déterminer les gens sont proches
voies de la chaussée
merci de rester sur le côté de la
chaussée donc ils sont ils peuvent
s'approcher de plus en plus et il voit
un cadeau sur la route et ils vont se
pencher pour le prendre le vélo on
s'arrête merci et il ne vaut il ne voit
plus le véhicule ils sont vraiment
orienté sur le cadeau est
la vision reste sur le cadeau et ne voit
plus rien à droite et à gauche
[Musique]
la chasse aux cadeaux est ouverte
un miracle tombé du ciel pour ceux qui
attendent depuis des heures
[Musique]
d'abord
du quoi
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
c'est le 14 juillet tout ça réuni un
village on est tous ensemble et puis les
petits enfants les cadeaux tout ça c'est
que du bonheur c'est chaleureux
c'est très chaleureux on n'a personne
tous à la télé mais là on le vit
vraiment
ce qui est assez intéressant dans la
caravane au département c'est que les
gens attendent la publicité durant la
verse un peu le rapport de le rapport de
force puisque en général quand on a de
la pub à la télé on zappe
là on reste maintenant la pub et puis
surtout parce qu'il faut attendre les
gens c'est quelque chose qui est gratuit
c'est un spectacle gratuit en plein air
ça demande si requins qui se déplace
et c'est près de 15 millions de cadeaux
qui sont distribués sur l'ensemble du
tour de france
on repart la maison avec des
échantillons des casquettes des produits
à consommer c'est plutôt sympa
[Applaudissements]
dans la montée du ventoux c'est la
couille l'affluence dépasse toutes les
prévisions
dans une ambiance de fête populaire
tout le monde cherche un endroit pour se
poser en attendant le passage de la
caravane et les places valent de l'or
[Musique]
on a trouvé une bonne place et les
embauches passée quand il avait gagné
son étape on avait vu que ça serait bien
que ça faisait juste un couloir juste
pour le porc est vraiment à étouffer
vraiment ça se resserre au niveau du
public 1 il ya beaucoup de demandes que
peu auparavant sas et ses mythiques le
mouvant toulouse c'est mythique
rien qu'hier descendre et remonter au
sommet c'est au tour du speaker officiel
du tour de france d'entrer en scène la
voix rocailleuse de daniel mangeas c'est
familière pour les passionnés de vélo en
40 ans il a commenté plus de 800 étape
mais pour lui le ventoux a une saveur
particulière c'est le le seul grand col
n'ya rien autour et asselah plane quand
on regarde de tous les côtés cc c'est le
seul dans cette région l'impression
qu'il est issu de la terre qui s'étaient
levés l'a sûrement pour peaufiner rendre
plus beau encore le parcours du tour de
france les voilà bien volontiers sa
place est ici est essentielle aux bons
jours françois bonjour à toutes et à
tous et par google se met un peu il faut
revoir la pierraille un manque d'oxygène
relatif il faut habiter les cordes
vocales à celui mobile met en route et
bien on est évidemment dans un site
mythique j'y reviendrai tout à l'heure
avec la montée du du manteau et des
salons sucre en bagarre puisque on l'a
vu le peloton n'est qu'à trois minutes
et n'a pas laissé se développer
l'échappée
[Musique]
pressé par les coureurs la caravane
commence son ascension
la foule est en délire pour les
chauffeurs évitez les spectateurs qui
envahissent la route est un véritable
challenge
pas question de ralentir un véhicule
pourrait être pris d'assaut par le
public
justin est étudiante c'est son troisième
tour de france
avec le temps elle est devenue une
spécialiste du lancer de saucisson
faut les en ont fait un vivier se serait
jeté par exemple la voiture surtout
comment c'est de voir un petit peu moins
vite ou on fait attention la marque
beaucoup de burqa
les
les regards il ya des fois on se croit
des coûts
sur les mains saumon sympa là on a
beaucoup de stock alors ils ne sont pas
du tout énervé
l'ambiance est très agréable
mêlant de plus de temps avec l'équipe
nordiste artistes nous avons
actuellement commandement le maillot
jaune
et là on dissout deuxième position on
est à 38 kilomètres de l'arrivée
c'est à dire que les coins sont à 15
kilomètres du pied du mont ventoux à
plus de 42 km heure de moyenne
le peloton fonce vers le mont ventoux la
montagne approche
christian prudhomme le directeur de
course donne ses dernières
recommandations avant la montée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
actuellement la tête et le peloton à
partir de faits doit d'avion au pied du
mont ventoux de bien vouloir ans passés
en tête de course
les voitures rouges voiture directeur
vente ils seront autorisés à l'échelon
de la côte merci donc à tout le monde de
respecter des conti
pour la régularité la sécurité d'accor
voici notre sélection pendant la cabine
ils sont arrivés après huit heures de
route
la caravane atteint le sommet et
distribuer ces derniers cadeaux
[Musique]
à 20 mètres de la ligne d'arrivée
c'est la panique en tête de la caravane
un véhicule casse son embrayage pas une
seconde à perdre il faut dégager le
passage
les coureurs ne sont qu'à quelques
kilomètres
les cyclistes arrivent au pied de la
montée lente à compagnons d'échappée
bonne surprise pour les français sylvain
chavanel est en tête mais ce n'est que
le début de la terrible ascension assez
sauvage en tête et après il ya les gros
et là que 25 secondes et maintenant à
une élite n 5 le peloton alors c'est
cuit 1
comment c'est dommage que nous on est
poitiers chavanel sa nouvelle bien quoi
chavanel il a une minute chacune il est
parti tout seul et bien rolland a été
décroché du peloton roulant est dans les
choux blanc était l'enjeu
[Applaudissements]
cabanel à 40 km de l'arrivée 15 km
chavanel ainsi la grande lessive
classement général pourrait subir
évidemment des changements très
importants donc alors que nous revenons
toujours avec un en tête donc sylvain
chavanel mais le peloton maillot jaune
est maintenant à moins d'une minute
il faudrait dire contre les cancers
trop de monde au bord de la route à
quelques mètres de là christian et son
ami préfère suivre la fin de la course
dans leur camping car le garder le
suspense vous ne savez pas qui est en
tête non non je ne veux pas savoir si
elle veut pas le voir la télé je suis
venu le voir en vrai tant que vous ne
savez rien de la course je ne suis rien
[Applaudissements]
fin de l'espoir pour les français
sylvain chavanel est rattrapé par
kintana
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et un canapé-lit tenté d'apporter les
autres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
thibault d albert ii
on
là
un nouveau talent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les obama est parti maintenant le
maillot jaune a attaqué à 7 kilomètres
de l'arrivée from bien de distance et
donc après un travail de richie porte
bien le berceau contador n'a pu suivre
leur et le public ont fully ne laisse
qu'un étroit passage pour les coureurs
un cauchemar pour christian prudhomme
qui doit veiller à la sécurité de ces
cyclistes et du public
votre nom
[Applaudissements]
dans la montée une lutte sans merci
s'engage entre alexander kintana et le
maillot jaune
l'anglais christopher froome
[Applaudissements]
il est un bon grimpeur je crois que
chris paul battre j'espère qu'il va le
faire
pour l'espagnol alberto contador et son
compatriote mikel nieve
il n'est plus question de victoire ils
vont rester ensemble pour se soutenir
jusqu'à l'arrivée
[Applaudissements]
l'abandon
christopher froome met fin à tout
suspense et assomme la course
c'est parti christopher froome vient de
prendre une dizaine de mètres clinton
avait répondu mais là il semble qu'elle
ça va être difficile donc pour kitana
qui permettra prennent à kehl et ses
permanences et s'en va seul fait d'armé
doit la longue silhouette donc de
christopher promis qu'il est en train de
devenir de plus en plus petit je suis
bientôt il est parti quand tu es bon tu
gagnes tu dis moi allons les ficelles et
les français chavanel dans les shoots on
avait posé voeckler n'a rien vu là dans
deux trois ans on serait qui s'est doté
le maillot jaune
âge et par son nouveau label des
morceaux
c'est le papa
c
si longtemps
et puis on s'en sortir de la cage des
jeux les remakes arrivée au sommet du
mont ventoux et d'une consécration de
gagner cette course contre un meilleur
cycliste du monde c'est fantastique
chavanel vont ils attaquer a fait ce
qu'il a pu mais bon il peut pas aller au
bout moi je me pose encore des questions
[Musique]
il en est toujours à la suspicion des
déceptions déception j'ai pas fait les
comptes et stablement porter candidat
pour lui une montagne de légende là
depuis une semaine avec hong kong à tous
les cyclistes que j'ai vu monter du plus
jeune au plus âgé
ce sont eux les vrais champions
dans quelques heures l'énorme machine du
tour de france désertera le sommet du
mont ventoux et la montagne retrouvera
sa quiétude
micheline christian et leurs amis vont
reprendre leur route tandis que la
caravane roule déjà vers la prochaine
étape
fille
c'est le must il faut une fois dans sa
vie avoir avoir fait lovano j'ai
certainement à la mecque voir là la pire
au noir donc to see this se doit d'avoir
fait le mans man dont la recette est
bien le village départ il ya toujours
aussi gentil dire aux petits as c'est
une très très belle étape très grande et
ce n'est pas la première fois qu'on l'a
fait encore le tout
on la connaît bien les gens sont fous je
crois que des camping cars 2 buts 5 6 et
camping cars depuis 25 ans je crois
qu'ils ont peut-être de ce qu'ont fait
évoluer la fête du tour de france je
crois que c'est ça d'après moi
[Musique]